for weeks Jeremy Hunt has been playing
the plane speaking medic for the UK's
economic malaise like root canal surgery
the treatment he's warned of won't be
pleasant but he insists it's necessary
and the moment has come in the face of
unprecedented Global headwinds families
pensioners
businesses teachers nurses and many
others are worried about the future so
today we deliver a plan to tackle the
cost of living crisis and rebuild our
economy
Jeremy Hunt's 66 billion dollar plan
increases taxes and cuts government
spending but though the tax Rises will
come now most spending cuts are deferred
till 2025 after the next election
to help soften the blows State pensions
and benefits will rise in line with
inflation and the national living wage
will rise too
it's the new Chancellor's attempt to
clear the wreckage left by his
predecessor's mini budgets of just six
weeks ago
quasi-quarteng sent the pound plunging
and interest rates soaring with billions
in unfunded tax cuts it cost quateng and
previous prime minister Liz trust their
jobs Jeremy Hunt is trying to be a safer
Pair of Hands he's trying to make the
case that the conservative party is
going to generate fiscal credibility for
the country but not damage Public
Services too badly with another round of
austerity so he's kept in cash terms
spending the same over the next two
years and pushed back the pain to 2025
for the next election so a bit of a trap
for the for the labor party the reality
of the situation is that britons will
have less money in their pockets as the
country enters recession even in the
wealthy English town of Saffron Walden
the need for food banks is soaring the
cost of living crisis and the impending
recession are going to affect people
from all types of society
and what we find is that when you live
somewhere affluent if you are struggling
it the poverty here it's hidden and it's
invisible Sophie says demand for food is
outstripping the amount they receive
does she see any light down the tunnel
uh no definitely not no no light at all
the chancellor says Global Financial
pressures are a storm that Britain must
face into but whether the origins are
foreign or domestic the UK is entering a
new age of austerity Rory challenge Al
Jazeera